january 24 1961
it was just another normal day for the
people of goldsboro north carolina
but then they stumbled upon this
a thermal nuclear bomb or hydrogen bomb
in their backyard
in a crater a few hundred feet away laid
a second bomb that they discovered
both bombs had fallen out of a plane
that crashed in the middle of the nights
the most shocking part one of the two
nuclear bombs had three of the four
trigger mechanisms activated
only a single switch prevented the bomb
from exploding
had one of the news gone off it would
have leveled the town with an explosion
250 times more devastating than the bomb
that destroyed hiroshima
the fireball alone would have been a
mile wide and the nuclear fallout would
have spread over much of america's east
coast reaching even washington dc and
new york
america probably would have assumed it
was a soviet union so they would
probably launch a counter-strike right
away which would lead to the soviet
union watching a counter-strike and boom
the world as we knew it would have been
over
and yet most americans had no idea just
how close they came to death on that
fateful day in 1961
but the thing was it wasn't a hostile
attack by the soviet union now these
news came from america's own u.s air
force
the nuclear-armed b-52 bombers had
accidentally crashed on u.s soil almost
triggering nuclear armageddon
these bombers were part of something
called operation chrome dome a strategy
by the us during the cold war where the
goal was to have 12 of these nuclear
bombers in the air at all times
so if the soviet union dared to launch
nuclear missiles the us would be ready
to retaliate as fast as possible but the
intense 24-hour missions and the fact
that the 12 bombers had to be airborne
at any given moment would push the
planes and their crews to the limits so
it wasn't long before more nuclear bombs
came crashing down on america by
america's own military
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime of my team subscribe for more if
you want to win a thousand dollars cash
you just have to be following me at jake
trend and you're automatically entered a
few of you have won already
watch out for fake accounts i will never
message you asking for money and this is
the story of operation chrome dome
[Music]
[Music]
operation chrome don't came about
because the us looked at the trend of
where the soviet union was headed with
their nuclear arsenal but looking at
trends isn't just good for geopolitics
and war it's also great for discovering
your next business idea that could be
the business idea that makes you
millions however researching trends and
looking for that next great business
idea is really hard and time consuming
that is where trends comes in basically
trends lets you in on the next big
startup ideas way before everyone else
hears about it here's how it works
trends team of expert business analysts
vet thousands of business ideas and
market trends then they send the best
ones straight to your inbox every week
and then you can put the business ideas
you like the most into action alongside
a like-minded community of over 16 000
members that are all rooting for your
success and you never know one of those
16 000 people could be your next big
investor or lifetime business mentor and
just like that trend saves you months of
research thousands of dollars and the
regret of not starting sooner it sounds
crazy but look at craig for example
craig had been running his business
nerdiness part time after getting some
harsh feedback from his friends at
trends he decided to reposition his
brand and focus on direct to consumer he
wanted to become the ben jerry's of
peanut butter and just like that in 2020
they did their first a million dollars
in revenue or technorec for example who
was a trans member when trent uncovered
signals that the indoor plant business
was set to boom the rec took that report
and launched a d2c plan startup he
announced the project in the trans
community received some valuable advice
from other members and started building
just 40 days later he raised 1.5 million
dollars in funding that is how trends
makes finding the next big thing a lot
easier and all you have to do to get
started is head over to trends.com jake
tran with the link below and sign up
when you use my link you'll also get a
seven day trial of trends for just one
dollar that's trends.co jake trying to
start your seven day trial for just one
dollar thanks to trent for sponsoring
this video
in december 1941 the japanese launched a
surprise attack on pearl harbor
and the us government had a very
specific kind of retaliation in mind the
atomic bomb
four years later the u.s successfully
launched the first test of an atomic
bomb in a new mexico desert under the
code name trinity let's not forget
that we are fighting for peace robert
oppenheimer one of the leading
scientists of the project later said
we knew the world would not be the same
two people
laughed
a few people cried most people were
silent
by now it was 1945 and world war ii was
coming to a close the u.s still had one
enemy left to defeat japan so a few days
after the successful trinity test the
leaders of the allied powers met to game
plan in private u.s president truman
told soviet leader joseph stalin that
the u.s had built a new weapon of
unusual destructive force stalin replied
that he would like to see the u.s make
good use of it against the japanese and
two weeks later they did
on august 6th and 9th 1945 the u.s
dropped atomic bombs on the japanese
cities of hiroshima and nagasaki
we saw this tremendous cloud rise
and it was the most unusual thing
it seemed to have a pedestal
and we had no idea what it was
leveling both cities and killing
hundreds of thousands of people
shortly after japan surrendered world
war ii was over i have received this
afternoon the unconditional surrender of
japan the war was finally over
we were so relieved and the world had
just entered into a new era with the
united states wielding the most powerful
weapon in the world
one
fire
it is essential that no country
gain ascendancy over the united states
in the development manufacture and
tactical use of atomic weapon after
joseph stalin saw the devastating impact
of these bombs his mission was clear the
soviet union needed their own atomic
bomb as soon as possible whatever the
cost
suddenly this project that's on paper
comes to reality and the
destructive possibilities of this bomb
were made clear
the soviets felt very vulnerable
and that spurs stalin into action it's
after the hiroshima and nagasaki bombing
that stalin
creates the crash program to catch up
and create the soviet nuclear weapon so
stalin brought in the best scientists he
could find he forced the slave workers
in the russian gulags to mine the
materials and he planted spies in the
u.s to provide him with vital
information
meanwhile the u.s government wasn't too
concerned about the soviets they thought
the soviet union didn't have the
materials the expertise or the
scientists to build such a bomb but by
august 29 1949 the u.s was caught by
surprise when the soviet union detonated
their first atomic bomb thanks to the
soviet spies they managed to build an
exact copy of the bomb the u.s dropped
on nagasaki and the nuclear arms race
was on
contain the soviet union don't allow it
to expand don't allow it to grow or to
gain any more influence
and if we do you know it's just going to
creep and creep and creep until they'll
be in our kitchens
truman decides to respond with an even
bigger and more destructive weapon
and this is the start of the arms race
this is the start of the escalation that
will last for decades
out of fear of falling behind in the
arms race the u.s government begin a new
project the hydrogen bomb a nuclear
weapon hundreds of times more powerful
than the atomic bombs they had dropped
on japan but many u.s advisors were
actually against the project they argued
that such a super bomb could become a
weapon of genocide and should never be
produced but these critical voices were
soon overruled and president truman gave
the go-ahead for the project
on november 1st 1952 the u.s detonated
the world's first hydrogen bomb on an
atoll in the pacific ocean the explosive
force
about 500 times more devastating than
the nagasaki bomb
but if the us government thought they
had won the arms race they were badly
mistaken
less than a year later the soviet union
shocked the u.s yet again their first
hydrogen bomb and had less explosive
force but one key advantage it was small
enough to be dropped from an airplane
the us government was in a panic and the
cold war was becoming more tense by the
day
another year passes and the u.s launched
another test of a hydrogen bomb under
the code name castle bravo unfortunately
the scientists miscalculated the power
of the bomb the explosive force was
actually three times bigger than
expected it produced a 15 000 kiloton
explosion
which is over 1 000 times more powerful
than the hiroshima bomb
[Music]
people who live 300 miles away suffer
from radiation poisoning and one crew
member of a japanese fishing boat died
the concern before the hydrogen bomb
was could we take shelter what the
hydrogen bomb tests reveal is that
that is inadequate there may be no
safety except run the battle for the
biggest hydrogen bomb went on for years
to come until the soviet union presented
their masterpiece the tsar bomba
explosive force
about 2 800 times more powerful than the
nagasaki bomb
it produced a 50 000 kiloton explosion
that's 3
300 times
more powerful than the hiroshima bomb
the mushroom cloud was so tall that it
dwarfed anything on earth
the bomb even needed a parachute to slow
down the fall so the pilot could escape
when the pilot landed so the plane was
highly warped skin buckled
and the pilot never flew again
he said he had done his job for the
motherland and he retired after the drop
after the explosion the soviet union
stated that
it could have been bigger than it might
have broken all the windows in moscow 4
000 miles away a bomb like this could
wipe out the entire city of los angeles
in a second and the nuclear fallout
would turn california into a wasteland
by this act the soviet union have added
injury to insult
they broke the moratorium
on nuclear weapons testing
they have raised atmospheric pollution
to new heights
they have started a new race
for more deadly weapons for today mr
chairman the world has taken a great
leap backward
toward anarchy and disaster
the united states and the soviet union
now had enough explosive power to
destroy each other there was just one
problem
these bombs still had to be carried by a
plane and it could take hours before
they reach the target
so it was no longer about explosive
power
now it was about speed who could get a
nuclear bomb to the enemy faster
[Music]
what if instead of carrying the bomb by
plane you simply launched it with a
missile with a speed of several thousand
miles per hour a missile could reach its
target in less than 30 minutes and by
launching dozens of missiles at once
there will be no way one could defend
them all you could annihilate a country
of your choice in less than half an hour
that was the next big project for the
united states and the soviet union the
intercontinental ballistic missile or
icbm
in 1957 it seemed like the united states
was winning the race
atlas an icbm with a top speed of about
16 000 miles per hour was ready for
testing but the test was a total
disaster
shortly after the launch the missile
plunged back to earth and only a month
later the soviet union beat them to the
chase apparently launching their first
successful icbm
some u.s experts doubted that it was as
successful as the soviets claimed but if
it was actually true no part of the
united states would be safe anymore with
a top speed of 15 000 miles per hour and
a distance of about 4 700 miles from
moscow to new york it would take less
than 20 minutes for these nuclear
missiles to reach new york or washington
u.s bombers wouldn't even be able to
make it off the ground in time to
retaliate to make things worse the
soviets started bragging that they were
cranking out missiles like sausages by
the early 1960s the us government was
certain that the soviets had 200 to 300
icbms ready for combat
and if the soviets pulled the trigger
the u.s could face nuclear annihilation
with no way to retaliate
gentlemen
this air intelligence briefing is secret
we've analyzed the soviet guided missile
test program in great depth the soviet
missile development program reveals that
it introduces a new dimension to
surprise
and forces us to reassess
our own strategic position and
re-evaluate the soviet's ability to deal
a crippling blow
[Music]
[Music]
what the us government now needed was a
deterrent strategy a clear message for
the soviets that if you dare to launch
your missiles we will annihilate you and
your country as well so operation chrome
dome was born their mission a dozen b-52
bombers airborne at all times each
carrying two to four hydrogen bombs they
would fly 24 hours a day 365 days a year
right outside the soviet airspace so
even if the soviets launched a first
strike and knocked out u.s airfields the
u.s would be right outside their
doorstep ready to drop bombs
the bombers had three different routes
the northern route towards greenland the
western route around alaska so that the
b-52s could attack the soviet union from
the east and the southern route across
the atlantic towards spain
there was just one problem these 24-hour
missions would push the planes and their
crews to the limit crew members had to
stay focused for 24 hours straight
without much sleep or proper food and if
something went wrong they would crash
down with several nukes on board and
things went wrong a lot more than
expected
[Music]
january 23 1961 a few months into
operation chrome dome the first critical
accident happened due to a few leak in
the right wing the crew lost control
their plane and bailed out the plane
crashed a few miles outside goldsboro
north carolina and one of the nukes fell
into a field at full speed the other
bomb landed slowly by parachute by the
time they checked the bomb they saw that
three of the four trigger mechanisms
were activated a single switch prevented
the first nuclear strike on u.s soil but
operation chrome dome was deemed too
important to call off
march 14 1961 only two months later the
next b-52 crashed the bomber was
suddenly having problems with cabin
pressure and the pilot had to descend to
a lower altitude but they burned too
much fuel in the process and knew they
wouldn't make it to the next tanker so
the crew bailed out near yuba city
california and the plane crashed with
two nuclear bombs on board once again
the world got lucky
january 13th 1964 the b-52 was returning
to georgia from massachusetts when the
pilot tried to avoid a heavy storm one
of the plane's stabilizers broke off
the crew lost control of the plane and
bailed out and two nuclear bombs went
down with the crashing plane near savage
mountain maryland
just three years into operation chrome
dome and six nuclear bombs had already
crashed on american soil
and so far none of them had exploded or
caused any radiation
but that luck would soon run out
january 17th 1966 a b-52 was flying the
southern route across the atlantic
towards spain during mid-air refueling
the bomber collided with the tanker the
fuel ignited and destroyed the tanker
killing all crew members the b-52 broke
apart and crashed near palomares a
village on spain's coast with four
hydrogen bombs on board
three nukes hit the ground near the
wreckage and two of them partially
detonated upon impact
there was no big nuclear explosion but a
large area around the wreckage was
contaminated
u.s personnel rushed in to start the
cleanup and shipped over six thousand
barrels of contaminated soil back to the
us but the fourth bomb was still missing
after about three months the u.s navy
finally found it on the ocean floor you
may think that almost blowing up spain's
coast would put an end to operation
chrome dome but the mission kept going
january 21 1968 hours into the flight a
cabin fire broke out in a b-52 flying
toward greenland the crew bailed out and
the plane crashed into the ice in north
star bay with four hydrogen bombs on
board the bombs partially detonated
causing radioactive contamination in the
area during the cleanup thousands of
tons of radioactive ice had to be
shipped to the united states it was the
end of operation chrome dome
in the eight years the operation ran 14
nuclear bombs had crashed down to earth
[Music]
the u.s government took a big risk when
they gave the go-ahead for operation
chrome dome it may have prevented a
nuclear war with the soviet union but it
also could have ended in the first
nuclear strike on u.s soil caused by the
air force itself in 2011 another huge
risk paid off the raid on osama bin
laden after the seals had assassinated
bin laden they discovered something
drastic in his compound a treasure trove
of computers hard drives notebooks and
printed files lying around on every
floor these files could contain
priceless intelligence it took the seals
an extra 18 minutes to collect this
treasure trove of 500 000 digital and
physical files
this intel collection would become known
as the bin laden papers for years most
of those files were kept classified but
in 2017 the cia finally declassified
over 470 000 of those files for the
world to see and what they contained was
shocking to say the least but here's the
thing a video that goes this deep into
bin laden's life his attacks and the
plans for the world is guaranteed to get
demonetized so that's why we just
released a brand new private documentary
going over the bin laden papers in all
its infamy the video has already been
age restricted and channel members have
been loving the documentary all you have
to do to get access to this documentary
right now and all the other documentary
length videos that are too controversial
too dark too risky to post publicly is
click the join button below
once you sign up you'll get exclusive
access to the bin laden papers plus
others every epstein monsanto the
company that owns the world's food
supply mk ultra and many more in the
future
these are the things they should be
teaching you in university about how the
world works but unlike university you
get all of this for just five dollars a
month and there's a refund policy too so
if you join and you don't think it's
worth it email us within your first
month of joining and we will personally
refund you for your first month after
your first month there's no refund
because a few bad apples decide to abuse
this refund policy pause the video and
click that join button below right now
hope you guys enjoyed the video and if
you're new here this is one of the
biggest channels on youtube for
documentaries on money power and crime
so if you enjoyed this video click that
subscribe button below if you want a
chance to win a thousand dollars you can
follow me on instagram jake tran but
that's gonna wrap it up stay dangerous
out there and i will see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
[Music]
you